i want to ask about matt ryan because
you know you have the fourth pick
you know a lot of people see that
quarterback you know we'll just kind of
how much have you thought about that and
where do you see matt ryan working in
next year with the falcons
well we got a long way to the draft uh
just like with anybody on our roster i
mean you know i'll be about
you i gotta earn my job every day so
we're excited about
players that we have and we want to
obviously go through the whole thing but
to give you
i can't make a statement today because
we there's a long process ahead of us
but matt ryan's it's been a terrific
quarterback and
and i got all the respect in the world
for matt ryan and i look forward to
working
let me just say this i love business
suit season in the nfl
when we see guys who otherwise never
wear a coat and tie and a dress shirt in
a coat and tie in a dress shirt
but why do they do it the coaches don't
wear suits anymore on the sidelines
they wear their officially licensed nike
gear why not have the coach
dressed at the press conference the
introductory press conference
the way he would be dressed for a game
i would not have known that that was
arthur smith
if you had shown me that photo earlier
today
even against the falcons backdrop i'd
have said well the co is talking today
about some new
charitable endeavor or something i would
have never known it was him i would have
never guessed it in a thousand years
that it was arthur smith
well these guys just need to wear what
they're comfortable in especially
because it is an inherently stressful
and uncomfortable situation anyway
they're never going to be wearing a suit
when they do their job i don't know why
they wear a suit
for the introductory press conference
and that's all i'm going to say about
that there's a question from nyada
thomas at twitter
can arthur smith have success in atlanta
with the falcons current
roster hashtag rise up sounds like a
falcons fan to me
i don't think you can have the kind of
success that you'll want to have i think
it's time
to tear it down and build it up they're
going to have cap issues this year
with or without matt ryan on the roster
with or without julio jones on the
roster and the thing to keep in mind
and we'll get some clarity on this at
some point before march 17.
what will the salary cap be for 2021
it won't be lower than 175. there's been
some talk that maybe it'll still be
around 195 so teams can properly operate
and
and manage their rosters not to cut a
bunch of guys i was told last night 180
is the number to keep an eye on that's
going to wreak havoc on some of these
teams and it's going to be a real
problem for the falcons and
if i was arthur smith i don't know that
this is the job i would have taken
there's a lot of factors we've talked
about before but stepping into this cap
mess
with a team that's just had this
lingering frustration that traces back
to super bowl 51
he's going to be a hot candidate next
year with derek henry and ryan tannehill
i i would have waited if i were him but
he didn't and we'll see what he can do i
just think it's going to be a challenge
right out of the gates because he's not
going to have the same quality of
players
that he had in tennessee on both sides
of the ball um so
yeah look i'm not i'm not i'm not trying
to
do anything other than wish him well i'm
just curious that a guy who seemed to
have so many options and seemed to be
in such demand would choose one of the
jobs that i had real misgivings about
going into this cycle all right that's
it for today but before we go
they've announced the full crew of
officials for super bowl 55 and for the
first time ever a female is on the crew
sarah thomas who's been an official now
for five six seven years it's kind of
flown by she's been
doing it she's been doing well and she's
done well enough to now get a super bowl
assignment it is based on merit it's not
random
it's not a rotation you've got to earn
that spot and she's done well enough
in the job to earn that spot and that
game is coming up it's amazing it's just
two and a half so wait a weeks away
we're gonna have the super bowl
and by all appearances they're gonna
pull it off although i'd rather not be
talking about the patrick mahomes
concussion this week it's better than
talking about coven the nfl has gotten
it under control
three games to go and we'll be here
every step of the way as the conference
championships approach
and then as the super bowl comes down
the pike that's it for today we'll see
you back here tomorrow everybody enjoy
your evening
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports